once you find out what it is that moves
and shakes you you don't want to do or
be anything else
and though i lost the ability to speak i
never lost my voice
so i'm a filmmaker with motor neurone
disease
eight years ago simon fitzmaurice was an
up-and-coming film director but just as
his career was taking off he was
diagnosed with motor neurone disease or
mnd
a degenerative condition also known as
als
doctors told him he had only four years
to live
every profession is inconvenient to
motor neurone disease but we don't
choose what moves us what drives us
it chooses us
it's up to you what you choose to do
about it he chose to fight his diagnosis
he learned to speak through a computer
and went on to write and direct his
first feature film when all this
happened it was my writing that saved me
like writing the passion of film has
never left me
my name is emily is both of my passions
combined so m d made me even more
determined to direct this film
him and he is defined by loss
by what it takes away but this was me
taking something back
i can write the script i can storyboard
choose frames with my dp i can make all
the hundreds of decisions that comprise
this job the biggest challenge in film
making that comes with m d is time
when i'm on set there's a short delay
while i type up my thoughts
i overcome this by preparing as much as
possible in advance of the shoot
simon and his wife have had three
children since his diagnosis
he says he wants to keep creating to
show his children the importance of
never giving up
when you love films as i do you simply
want to contribute to add my voice to
the art form i love
i once thought of mnd as a prison camp
to which no liberating army would ever
come
but i outgrew the prison
i am free
you